foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar role of
serology for congenital infections and
vaccine preventable diseases in the
prenatal setting
I am Kaylee Bach of Labyrinth and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by biorad Laboratories
to learn more visit bio-rad.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
so I'd now like to welcome our speakers
Dr Alan Wu Professor lab medicine
University of California San Francisco
co-core lab director Zuckerberg San
Francisco General Hospital
and Dr Russell nooner research and
development manager at biorad
laboratories
Dr Wu I'll pass it over you may now
begin your presentation
welcome to the next webinar sponsored by
lab roots
today's topic is the laboratory's role
in preventing prenatal infections
my name is Alan will and I'm from the
University of California San Francisco
and the Zuckerberg San Francisco General
Hospital
let's start off with some statistics
on this slide I show pregnancy outcomes
during intrauterine infections
among stillborn births
about 10 to 30 percent of cases have
some infectious disease etiology
among live births about three percent
have some congenital anomaly
and the fetal death rate ranges from
three percent for pyro virus b19 to as
much as 50 percent for T pallidum the
Infectious agent
um that causes syphilis
Laboratory Testing has been defined by
this acronym torch first coined in 1971
by Dr Andre namies of Emory University
T stands for toxoplasmosis
o is kind of a catch-all it includes
other infections that might be syphilis
HIV hepatitis
varicella and parovirus
R stands for rubella
C stands for subtle megalovirus and H is
herpes simplex
vulnerable populations for these
infections includes those who are
immunocompromised such as those with HIV
transplant recipients the elderly and
the infants
and particularly relevant for this stock
are the vulnerability of fetuses During
the pre-natal period
about a dozen years ago there was a
survey conducted of Obstetricians
knowledge of prenatal infections
and most of these doctors understood
that their patients should avoid
cleaning litter boxes cooked meat until
they're well done get tested for HIV
avoid contact with people who have been
infected
keeping up to date with vaccines hand
washing and avoid exposures to Wild or
pet rodents
lesser known was not sharing utensils
with toddlers not getting babies saliva
into eyes and mouths and this one I
didn't know about they should be
avoiding licking envelopes
the other questions asked in the survey
was the percentage of respondents who
console patients about how and why to
prevent infections and these are the
target infections that they counsel
their patients on and you can see here
that many of these infections are
included within the torch panel
I want to now start talking about
specific microorganisms that can produce
congenital infections
in each of these next slides I'll first
talk about the route of administration
the pathophysiologic effects that these
infections have on the neonates
and the current status of vaccines
let's start with Toxoplasma Gandhi
this is an intracellular protozoan has
been said to be the most successful
parasite in the world today
with about 30 percent of the population
infected
the parasite is shown in below
the definitive host is the domestic cat
s excrete into their feces oocytes
that become sporulated and then can be
can transmit into an immediate hosts
through the food supply water supply and
exposure to soil
in the pregnant woman
infected uncooked meat from these
secondary hosts can lead to a Toxoplasma
infection
these infections infections then can
transmit through the placenta Into The
Unborn fetus
this slide shows the clinical
presentation of congenital toxoplasmosis
the most notable effects are in the
brain this includes the presentation of
hydrocephalus
microcephaly which is a smaller than
unusual size of the head
encephalopathy each of these leading to
mental retardation
infants may be asymptomatic at Birth but
during their childhood they can develop
these problems
PCR is used to confirm the diagnosis in
neonates
also Toxoplasma antibodies particularly
IGG is used to determine negativity or
disappearance of on serial testing as a
means to exclude congenital infections
this is the release pattern of
toxoplasmosis antibodies over time
you can see here that within a few weeks
of infection
there is the release of the IGM antibody
that over the course of several months
several converts to IGG
there is a time when both of these
antibodies are present
over time eventually
the IGG becomes the predominant form and
the levels of IGM decline
this can be very useful in pinpointing
the time of infection because if a
mother is infected actively during
pregnancy this is a most dangerous time
for that child
one of the tests that can be used to
determine the temporal relationship of
antibodies in addition to the relative
levels of IGG and IGM
is a test known as IGG alvidity
the avidity of an antibody is described
as how tightly bound is the antibody to
its antigen and there are avidity tests
available for circulating antibodies
an antibody that has low avidity as
shown in the top part of the slide can
be displaced with urea
of antibodies that have high avidity are
resistant to displacement with urea
this slide goes over the interpretation
of Toxoplasma serology when they're both
negative clear that it indicates no past
or recent infection
when the IGG is positive and indicates
immunity to toxoplasmosis and subsequent
pregnancies are safe when the IGM is
alone positive this would indicate very
early positive infection or it's a
potential for a false positive result
nevertheless
um
testing should be repeated in two to
four weeks to see if there is IGG serial
conversion
when they're both positive this is
suggestive of an acute infection
the IGG avidity test can help us confirm
this notion when low it indicates that
this is in fact a recent infection and
requires treatment to avoid congenital
toxoplasmosis
however if the avidity is high even with
the presence of IGM antibodies it
indicates an infection out by at least
four months and a pregnancy is safe and
no treatment is necessary
there are no Toxoplasma vaccines
available to date this is a recent paper
published last year that looks at live
attenuated virus against research mice
strains the
wh3 and wh6 strains and you can see here
in red unvaccinated individuals and the
percent survival is very low as opposed
to mice that have been vaccinated with
these two with these two live viruses
showing tremendous Improvement I'm
hopeful that we can achieve a Toxoplasma
vaccines sometime in the next few years
okay so let's move on to German Measles
German Measles is also known as rubella
it can be transmitted via respiratory
droplets in the similar manner as SARS
cov2
in the pregnant female
the virus can be transmitted through the
placenta and onto the growing fetus and
and into a newborn
this is the clinical manifestations of
congenital rubella similar to what we
saw with toxoplasmosis you see the
microcephaly you see the Encephalitis
you can see hearing loss there is in
addition congenital heart disease
bone disease
and thrombocytopenia the propura is the
presence of these blood underneath the
skin due to damaged blood vessels
not to confuse German Measles with
measles which is
paramixoviridae and chickenpox which is
viricella zoster all three of these
conditions produce a skin-like lesions
known as pox but upon closer examination
there is a differentiation in the
morphology of these pox and therefore an
indicative of this different disease
etiologies
uh there has been a rubella vaccine
available for many decades here are some
data prior to the vaccine that was
created in 1964 or 1965 for where there
are over 12 million cases rubella and
many thousands of cases of congenital
rubella syndrome resulting in many
infants who became deaf blind
intellectually disabled and resulting in
a number of neonatal deaths
it also led to a number of abortions
both both combination of elective when
the parents found out that there was a
rubella infection
or spontaneous
in 1969 a live attenuated virus was
released and a couple years later it was
put into combination with the measles
mumps and rubella vaccine the so-called
MMR vaccine
today
size for Disease Control recommend
children get two doses of this vaccine
one within the first year of birth and a
second one at four to six years of life
as a result of this rubella vaccine
similar to the success story with polio
we have largely eradicated rubella in
the United States and most people have
positive antibodies
there are a number of countries for
which rubella continues to be endemic
those countries are listed in this slide
if you practice in a location in the U.S
that has a lot of foreign travelers from
these countries this test becomes
important especially for pregnant women
the next on our list is CMV or
cytomegalovirus as shown in this Slide
the route of administration is quite
diverse in addition to respiratory
droplets as seen through coughing or
sneezing there can be oral transmission
through oral fluids
um blood transfusions sexual contact
contact with infected urine and feces
transplantation of organs
and vertical transmission either through
the placenta or through breast milk
when a fetus a newborn suffers from
congenital CMV infection these are the
clinical manifestations again very
similar to some of these other
infections microcephaly and about half
of the cases they can be hearing loss in
about a third
thrombocytopenia low platelet count
cardioretinitis
hepatomegaly with increased liver
function tests and sphingomegaly
and in particular
interuterine growth restriction which is
iugr about 40 percent of cases this is
characterized by poor growth rate in
utero none of these things are favorable
despite Decades of effort there are
currently no CME vaccines available
today
CMV was discovered
in 1956 by the same research team that
discovered polio mumps and rubella
the first attempts at vaccine was
published in 1984
in the year 2000 there was an economic
report conducted in the U.S that
concluded that a CME vaccine would be
highly cost effective we'll be talking
about cost effectiveness of testing
later in this presentation
in 2009 to 2012 there were some
promising results for two different
types of CME vaccines however neither
one of them reached FDA clearance and
despite the fact that we have vaccines
for polio measles mumps and rubella CMV
has been left behind and in this set of
tongue-in-cheek Slide the author said
can we get a vaccine to pension CMV
before it reaches the age of 65.
let's move on now to HSV or herpes
simplex virus
this slide shows the route of neonatal
exposure
HSV is transmitted through sexual
intercourse it starts with an infection
on presence in male genitalia in the
form of shankers which then gets
transmitted to female genitalia which
then transmits in utero to
neonates and with a 20 to 50 percent
risk of transmission
the clinical manifestations of neonatal
herpes as shown here there can be
central nervous system involvement there
can be skin lesions and mucous membrane
involvement
the presentation includes
Encephalitis respiratory failure hepatic
failure
DIC
can lead to seizures lethargy
irritability feeding problems
temperature instability with rash
and the mortality can in fact be fairly
significant
we don't have a herpes vaccine at the
moment but I am encouraged by this note
that was published a couple of months
ago
the company biontech has
dosed its first patients in clinical
trials for their vaccine
zika
is not part of the O in the torch panel
but I thought I would talk about it
the mode of transmission is through the
mosquito
the mosquito bites a male which can then
through sexual intercourse
transmit the infection to a pregnant
woman who can then transmit it to the
fetus and neonate either through
interuterine transfer to form congenital
zika
or through post
partum transmission via breast milk the
virus is present in both placental cells
and amniotic fluid amongst other body
fluids
the clinical manifestations
include fetal loss
congenital
zika syndromes with microcephaly in a
minority of cases
the majority of cases are in fact either
asymptomatic or unaffected so the rate
of transmission is only 20 to 30 percent
there are no zika vaccines available but
there are some experimental reports this
one was published six months ago looking
at a experimental vaccine developed in
mice
slide a shows immunization with the
vaccine booster injection two weeks
later then challenging the mice with the
virus doing blood testing and then
determining efficacy
you can see here in the preliminary data
that um individual individual mice who
are treated with the vaccine did better
than those who were unvaccinated
this was an interesting headline that I
found in one of the vaccine tabloids
entitled massive zika vaccine trial
struggles as researchers revive a plan
to intentionally infect humans The
Disappearance of zika in the Americas
predominantly South and Central America
is making it difficult to conduct these
vaccine trials and so what is considered
is infecting individuals with vaccine
and then seeing if they can be treated
now let's talk about strategies for
torch antibody testing
bedside testing is available using
lateral flow point of care devices that
are multiplexed and enables you to
simultaneously measure each of the five
members of the panel
these are designed for individual
patients they're not really amenable to
high volume testing situations
and sometimes these endpoints on lateral
flow can be ambiguous
the central laboratory uses instruments
where individual immunoassays are
available one assay per Channel
but very useful in reference
Laboratories that have a high volume of
samples however for a hospital-based
laboratory you may not want to consume
that many channels for immunoassay
antibody testing
a third approach would be to use a
multiplexed bead assay such as what's
shown here the bioplex 2200
it does allow you to put together other
panels without consuming a lot of
reagent space
the individual tests however have to be
validated to ensure that there is no
crosstalk between antibodies
and the next lecture in this webinar
will describe the steps that biorad has
taken in constructing this assay
I would like to conclude my webinar by
discussing some medical economics for
torch testing can we justify screening
tests for pregnant women
medical economists use something called
the quality adjusted life year as a
metric to determine the effectiveness of
some type of intervention whether it be
treatment surgery or pharmacology
as shown in this slide here without that
treatment there can be a certain life
expectancy
that is improved with the initiation of
treatment
the gap between these two curves is
known as the Q a l y gain now this can
be Quantified in dollar amounts simply
as the incremental cost Effectiveness
Ratio or icer it is the cost of the
experimental procedure minus the cost of
the control divided by the Q a l y of
the experiment
virus that of the control
this slide shows the cost Effectiveness
for other types of interventions and
comparing that to prenatal screening so
for colorectal screening using occult
blood it's three thousand dollars per
live saved per year
cholesterol screening 6000
mammography screening for breast cancer
about 19 000.
as you can see here triple marker
testing as well as prenatal
toxoplasmosis testing is roughly around
those limits
now what is the threshold for
acceptability what is the willingness to
pay for such interventions it is
typically somewhere between 50 and 100
000 per life saved
under this metric
the prenatal testing for infectious
disease which is something that we're
not doing can be justified
the CPT code for torch tests from using
2019 prices are shown here note that
there is no torch panel that the
individual tests are separately
reimbursed as listed here
up roughly about 16 to 21 dollars
in conclusion serology tests are widely
available by diagnosing torch infections
despite the significant medical effects
of congenital infections prenatal
screening has not been endorsed by
clinical practice groups this is despite
the fact that cost analysis suggests
that screening is economically
justifiable I want to thank you for
tuning in to this webinar and I would
like to thank lab roots for hosting this
platform
great thank you Dr Wu I'd like to now
pass it over to Dr nooner
hello my name is Russell nooner and I am
a r d manager in the clinical Immunology
group at biored
today I will be speaking with you about
the laboratory role in containing
vaccine preventable diseases with a
primary focus on the mmrv vaccine
mmrv is an acronym that stands for four
different viral diseases measles mumps
rubella also known as German Measles
and varicella zoster
all four diseases are present worldwide
and are preventable through a full dose
vaccination program
children typically receive a two-dose
vaccine between the ages of one in five
years of age
health care workers due to their high
risk on the job should be immune to
these infectious agents
diagnostic testing can be used to
determine serological status
and a comprehensive determination of
serological status provides the
opportunity to reduce the spread of
these highly contagious diseases
measles is a disease that is transmitted
through respiratory secretions or
directly from person to person
the incubation period is between 10 to
12 days with a skin rash occurring
approximately 14 days after exposure
symptoms can also be severe ranging from
diarrhea ear infections or Broncho
pneumonia
in developing countries the fatality
rate can be up to 25 percent caused by
acute encephalitis
mumps is a disease that is transmitted
through respiratory secretions or
directly from person to person
the incubation period is between 16 to
18 days with classical symptoms
presenting as bilateral perititis fever
headache or malaise
children typically do not develop severe
symptoms
however it is becoming more common that
teenage boys and men develop infertility
or sub-fertility
perinatal mumps remain rare
huh
rubella is a disease that is transmitted
through respiratory secretions or
directly from person to person
it is caused by the Ruby virus and is
predominantly asymptomatic in the
majority of infected people
however when symptomatic it presents as
a low-grade fever headache sore throat
or skin rash
rubella can have severe consequences
during pregnancy resulting in
miscarriage stillbirth or fetal
anomalies
and presently to date there is no
antiviral treatment or rubella
varicella zoster or vzv is a disease
that is transmitted through respiratory
secretions or directly from person to
person
it is a highly contagious disease and is
most commonly known as chickenpox
the incubation period is between 10 to
21 days with the most common symptom
being a skin rash
a systematic infection usually results
in lifetime immunity
severe symptoms can be in adults and in
the immunocompromised
the vcv virus can also remain dormant in
sensory nerve ganglia until later in
life where reactivation can cause herpes
zoster or more commonly known as
shingles
so why should we test for mmrv
antibodies such as IGG
understanding a person's immune status
provides the opportunity to reduce the
spread of highly contagious diseases
this is especially important as these
diseases can be prevented through a full
dose vaccination program or booster
vaccine
IGG serology screening is a valuable
tool in preventing prenatal infections
by identifying maternal immune status
in addition IGG testing is useful for
pre-employment screening such as
Healthcare or military workers to
prevent unnecessary vaccinations when
immune status is unknown
despite the tremendous progress made by
worldwide vaccination programs measles
remains a public health problem in
Europe
in 2018 alone more than 21
000 cases were reported
this was the highest number of cases in
the past decade and was three times the
total number of measles cases in 2017.
there are indications that a further 300
percent increase is expected in more
recent years
after a two-dose vaccine regimen the
efficacy rates for mmrv all remain very
high ranging from 96 percent
to 99 percent
mmrv is largely eradicated in the U.S
however there have been recent measles
outbreaks reported
the outbreaks have been due to
unvaccinated children and adults who
experience waning immunity over a long
period of time
vaccine preventable diseases have been
re-emerging despite sustained High
vaccine coverage
as shown in the figure on the right
before vaccination highly contagious
diseases such as measles and mumps were
common in young children in the
incidence of disease was high
upon natural infection a person's
antibody tighter level elevated and then
throughout life repeat exposures and
infections from Community outbreaks
served as natural boosting events which
helped to retain a person's antibody
tighter level
now in the vaccine era after a two-dose
vaccination a person's antibody level
becomes elevated
however in the absence of community
outbreaks there are no opportunities for
natural boosting
therefore vaccine-induced immunity May
Wane more rapidly compared to immunity
from a natural infection
this however May differ depending on the
target disease and certainly each
person's immune system
an example of this is mumps reemergence
appears linked to waning vaccine
immunity also known as secondary vaccine
failures
however for measles outbreaks remain
concentrated in areas of poor
vaccination rates and the role of waning
immunity is unclear
to conclude this study further resource
research incorporating immunological and
epidemiological data are critical to
determine the best path for preventing
the re-emergence vaccine preventable
diseases
in our next section I will be discussing
how to improve workflow efficiencies in
infectious disease prenatal settings by
showcasing the bioplex 2200 system
solution
as Dr Wu mentioned in his presentation
torch testing is a high priority for
testing during the prenatal period
prenatal testing for torch is used to
determine exposure to infectious agents
that can cause congenital diseases
the bioplex 2200 system offers novel
Multiplex panels to simultaneously
identify and differentiate antibodies
for these infectious diseases
here at biorad we offer three infectious
disease panel products on our bioplex
2200 system
the first two are torque IGG and IGM
panels for detection of antibodies to
Toxoplasma Gandhi
rubella and cytomegalovirus
the second is HSV IGG panel for
detection of antibodies to HSV-1 and
hsv2
in addition we offer a mmrv idg panel
for a detection of antibodies to measles
mumps rubella and vcv
this product provides a solution for
streamlined assessment of vaccine
preventable diseases to determine if a
vaccine or booster is recommended
the design of the bioplex mmrb idg
product offers many workflow advantages
to our customers
in traditional testing a patient sample
is consumed by four independent single
analyte tests in the case of mmrv this
is a single test for measles a single
test for mumps a single test for rubella
and a single test for vzv
so traditional testing provides four
separate test results to the clinician
in bioplex 2200 testing the system uses
the power of multiplexing technology to
consume a patient sample in a single
test
this improved workflow provides four
test results to the clinician and up to
400 test results per hour
by harnessing the power of multiplexing
with the bioplex 2200 system a clinician
can receive multiple results from a
single test
this technology uses small microsphere
beads that contain multiple
fluorescently dyed barcodes
each unique bar coded bead is labeled
with a different disease specific
antigen
for example in the bioplex mmrv IGG
panel there are four individual assay
beads one for measles one for mumps one
for rubella and a fourth for vzv
together with three quality control
beads
that are mixed
and combined together to create the mmrv
IGG assay
bioplex 2200 system improves result
throughput and turnaround time by
generating multiple results in a single
test
it eliminates time-consuming sample and
reagent preparations dramatically
reduces sample volume requirements which
all help to lower overall costs and
labor
bioplex panel design starts with the
selection of high quality antigen
biomarkers
for the mmrv IGG panel this included
screening recombinant viral antigens to
identify the presence of IGG class
antibodies associated with measles
months rubella and vzv
three additional dyed beads are mixed
and combined in the assay
and they serve as internal quality
control beads to verify detector
response to verify the addition of serum
or plasma sample and to verify the
absence of significant non-specific
binding in the assay
during assay optimization our team
develops the hetero heterogeneous assay
format which includes the assay protocol
singleplex versus Multiplex analytical
and clinical performance is confirmed
as well as extensive cross-reactivity
testing that helps to reduce
non-specific binding and alleviate assay
interferences
in addition extensive verification and
validation testing is performed
according to the clinical and laboratory
standards Institute guidelines
these studies include Precision between
lab reproducibility assay linearity for
quantitative assays interference limit
of detection and reagent calibrator in
control stability
every bioplex product undergoes multiple
quality control procedures throughout
the entire manufacturing process from
raw material to formulation to component
and Final kitting
each bead is manufactured in Q seed
individually
and then further tested in a multiplex
assay format prior to final kit release
each panel contains internal assay QC
beads that help verify assay performance
overall our QC procedures help to
minimize lot to lot variation and create
a high quality product
to summarize the bioplex 2200 system is
a fully automated Random Access easy to
use diagnostic testing platform
it uses primary tube sampling and only 5
microliter sample volume for the mmrd
panel
it has electronic reflex test add-on
capability and is compatible with the
majority of laboratory automated track
lines
bioplex panel products are high
throughput
and with up to 400 tests per hour for
the mmrv panel
the diagram shown on the right shows the
entire infectious disease product
portfolio that is currently available
for the bioplex 2200 system
and lastly at biorad quality is at the
heart of everything we do and is
integral to our guiding principles and
core values
I would like to thank you for attending
thank you for attending today
sponsored by Library
well thank you Dr Wu and Dr nooner for
your informative presentations we will
now start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
so let's get started we've got some
great questions coming in from our
audience here so I have a first question
here directed towards Dr nooner and this
question asks what is the difference
between determining serological status
and immune status
um so the FDA defines serological status
as the detection of IGG or IGM
antibodies
uh while the immune status is defined as
the detection of both IGG and IGM
antibodies
so in terms of the clinical perspective
knowing the immune status can inform
clinicians that a patient has sufficient
antibodies to consider themselves immune
or protected against a disease
for serological status though if a
patient is negative
this means no antibodies are detected
and therefore the patient is either
unvaccinated
or has never been exposed to a disease
or possibly has waning antibodies that
fell below the limit of detection of the
assay used
the patient is positive
this means antibodies are detected and
the patient is likely protected against
a disease
great thank you my next question here is
for Dr Wu and this question asks I
notice these assays are not recommended
or included in the guidelines
yeah I think that's something that needs
uh to be addressed
um there has to be key opinion leaders
who write these guidelines and get
together and say this is both medically
and economically useful particularly for
the Neil Nate and I think the time now
is ripe because we do have these assays
that are multiplexed and are high volume
but it does require people to to make
that a priority within their
professional groups and right now I'm I
don't see that happening and I don't not
sure how to make it happen
great thank you Dr Wu I have another
question for you here and this one asks
you mentioned that there are vaccines in
development for several congenital
infections do you see the landscape for
Diagnostic testing changing with the
introduction of new vaccines for example
CMV
yes uh in a similar way that we have
tested individuals who have been
vaccinated with covet just to ensure
that antibodies have been produced and
that the person is safe that we should
expect to see some of that following
some of the newer virus vaccines that we
hope will show up in the future
in terms of
testing everybody routinely
we don't do that now for covid the CDC
says only in high risk groups would that
make sense and I suspect that that will
be the case with some of these other
virus vaccines
great
Mr neuter I have another question for
you here and this one asks why do you
think we are seeing outbreaks today in
the world of vaccination
this is a great question and um I'd like
to use measles as an example
um I think what we are seeing now for
possibly the first time ever in the
history of vaccinations is the majority
of adults have never had a natural
measles exposure
vaccine immune waning is an important
contributor to the cause of outbreaks
then it is only now that these effects
are being revealed
however it's important to remain
Vigilant and keep an open mind when
recognizing secondary vaccine failures
if and when they occur
right
all right I have another question for
you Dr nooner and this question asks
does biograd offer as well as or excuse
me as well a mmrb IGM kit
uh yes we do
um and it is also commercially available
on our website
great
all right another question here for Dr
Wu this question asks many current
guidelines and recommendations have
removed routine screening of pregnant
persons for HSV can you speak to this
yeah I'm disappointed with that that I
don't think that that is um
a good move I think that that should
stay in there perhaps it was removed
because
um the incidence of um congenital herpes
was uh was not high and again it's all a
matter of economic justification I
showed in my slide that's clearly
toxoplasmosis it's economically viable
for screening but we haven't seen the
same thing for herpes
right
well we are going to
concession there today so Dr nooner Dr
Wu do you have any final comments for
our audience
well I just want to say to everybody
who's listening to uh you know stay
vigilant and and try to maintain good
infection control practices we that work
in The Clinical Laboratory as well as
people at industry who are exposed to
specimens are at higher risk and that
when vaccines do become available such
as in covid
um that you embrace them
and and I would Echo Dr Wu's uh sediment
as well and uh I just want to say thank
you to everyone that attended and uh
also a thank you to our sponsored lab
roots for today's webinar
great well thank you again Dr Wu and Dr
nooner for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor biograd
Laboratories for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye